a modern music festival at a World
Heritage Site
DJ bunco mood is warming up the crowd at
the electromagnetic festival last year
it was judged the best new festival in
Europe that may have had a lot to do
with the festival site the former
flickinger ironworks in the state of
czar lund it's perfect tense to meet
aliens there's a lot of Steel another
metal that has an effect on people it's
not as much dimensional lattice baboon
its a mix of old and new culture it's
totally cool jakub dil snarling kamut is
one of the festival's main attractions
last year one of his remixes was top of
the charts in Germany Austria and
Switzerland I suppose if I the whole
design of the place and the industrial
atmosphere is really impressive technos
essentially industrial music anyway so
it's appropriate to play it at a place
where people used to work yeah altima
machine head's avatar Lord apartments
country girls asking us how come Germany
produces so much electronic music a lot
of it comes from northern England that's
where it started Belgium tube those are
all industrial regions people live there
have absorbed the pulse on the metal
machinery in the factories it's in their
heads it's even under DNA in Vienna
Donata Venice they produced iron and
steel here for nearly 100 years the
plant was closed in 1986 and became a
world heritage site in 1994 mine rod
gray Vanek is head of the facility the
fur clinger site is the world's last
fully preserved Industrial Age Iron
Works it covers six hundred thousand
square meters clay Vanek is committed
not only to preserving the facility but
also to breathing new life into it with
cultural events for example an
exhibition with internationally renowned
street artists epic I of Melissa we
consider the Iron Works and offspring of
pop culture would pop art has always had
a strong focus on industry and mass
production and it was through
its association with pop culture that
this site which was once a centre of
industrial production as now for the
first time become a cultural symbol
bhagavad during the industrial age
factories were overheated noisy and
dirty the working conditions were tough
in coking plants Cole was heated to
temperatures of up to 1200 degrees
Celsius back in the 1960s the foot
clinger ironworks employed up to 17,000
people after World War two the rural
coal and steel plants faced heavy
competition from overseas with the
result that they were being shut down
one after the other this huge gas ometer
in the ruhr valley town of oberhausen
has been converted into an exhibition
space right now it's featuring works by
the famous bulgarian born artist Cristo
last weekend the roar district
celebrated its annual culture festival
called extra sheet or extra shift more
than 200,000 people attended the Kaaba
that's not when I was younger I worked
at various mines and coking plans so
when I come to the cultural events here
at X fascist it's like reliving the past
it's a lot of fun that's ensuring you
deal i could have just torn it down and
put up a stupid shopping centre but they
preserved it and i think that's great
what no nuts in school one of the
festival events was held at the hind
researcher works in hatting in actors
staged a noisy performance using tools
from a bygone age
old industrial sites in Germany have
undergone a transformation in recent
years they've become an artistic
inspiration for some a performance stage
for others the work was hot and dirties
but there was also a sound to it and the
workers took that sound home with them
and woke up with it it was part of her
life spot asleep and this transformation
of former industrial sites continues in
other countries too for example six
facilities in Britain have now been
designated World Heritage Sites compared
to four in Germany occasionally part of
the science revert to their natural
state like here at the filling or
ironworks here in the back vegetation
has been growing wild for years so a
landscape architect turned the area into
a series of 12 garden areas this is our
paradise it's a really special place the
coking plant was a hellish place and now
25 years after the plant was shut down
nature has reclaimed this part not so
uncle would but once a year techno music
fans take over the former ironworks
10,000 people gather here to dance and
enjoy themselves until the early morning
hours that seven thousand fewer people
than used to work here but at least
modern culture has provided a new lease
on life for these industrial ruins